hi my name is James Cole I'm a medical
laboratory scientist the term micro RNA
has been used in 58,000 indexed works
all the works support claims that link
the anti-entropic virus idol energy of
sunlight from endogenous RNA
interference to biophysical constrained
protein folding chemistry and cell type
differentiation for comparison news from
last week reported physicists make the
case that our brains learning is
controlled by entropy on the same day
george church spoke during the
highest-profile lecture program at the
nih his topic was at the future of
genetic codes and brain codes but he
failed to link energy dependent
endogenous RNA interference or exogenous
RNA interference to the genetic codes or
the brain codes for contrast the systems
complexity of energy dependent top-down
RNA mediated causation is detailed here
the details can be compared to claim so
that minimal mutational differences
might link energy and/or entropy to the
evolution of all morphological and
behavioral diversity on earth via DNA
what I've done is to link quantized
energy as information from chirality and
hydrophobicity to thermodynamic cycles
of protein biosynthesis and degradation
lye as a potential of hydrogen which is
referred to as pH pH links the sun's
anti-entropic virus idle energy from
hydroxylation to the de novo creation of
nucleic acids and hydrogen atom transfer
in DNA base pairs in solution
photosynthesis links the creation of G
protein-coupled receptor genes from the
innate immune system to nutritional
epigenetics and Auto fudging pH taxes
chemotaxis thermo taxes and phototaxis
linked micro RNA biogenesis and micro
RNA flanking sequences from hydrogen
energy dependent changes in the micro
RNA messenger RNA balance to auto
fashion Auto fudging it links everything
known about nutritional epigenetics from
alternative splicing zuv pre messenger
RNA to nutrient dependent amino acid
substitutions for example feedback loops
link odors and pheromones to the
physiology of reproduction in all
vertebrates by a substitution of a
chiral lysine in position six of the
gunatit rope and releasing hormone deca
peptide simply put endogenous RNA
interference clearly linked RNA directed
DNA methylation from DNA repair to super
coiled DNA and healthy longevity in all
living genera via succession of a chiral
glycine and/or fixation of other amino
acid substitutions in all species for
comparison excess stress links reduced
pH to virus driven energy best and
genomic entropy liya transgenerational
epigenetic inheritance the cited works
that support the details in this poster
link epigenetically effected changes in
amino acid substitutions to cell type
differentiation from archaea to Zika
virus damaged human DNA when that fact
is considered in the
contexts of the precision medicine
initiative it becomes clear that virus
driven energy theft links neural
circuitry odor headaches mood memory
motivation expressions of affect
cognitive behavioral State and
potentiating responses to other stimuli
from nutritional and/or social stress to
mutations and all pathology in the
context of the precision medicine
initiative prevention of pathology is
achieved only in the context of
nutritional epigenetics and the national
microbiome initiative the national
microbiome initiative links energy
dependent fixation of nutrient dependent
amino acid substitutions to super coiled
DNA which protects all organized genomes
from virus driven energy theft that fact
helps to explain why exogenous RNA
interference might sometimes be
effective if it restores nutrient
energy-dependent viral latency the
failure to restore viral latency can now
be placed into the context of three
recent additions to the merriam-webster
dictionary title remediation microbiome
and CRISPR taken together the dictionary
definition of these terms replaces ideas
about evolved biodiversity that were
based on DeVries 1902 definition of
mutation that definition led to the
assumptions of population geneticists
who never linked energy dependent
metabolic networks to genetic networks
via
and dajin a--'s RNA interference and the
physiology of reproduction
thank you